it's time for a pick from the little
yellow book which is my personal guide
of things that i love that i think you
might want to know about but today we're
here with audrina biges
from cbs2 chicago's morning news she's
been with us throughout the entire show
and audrina
you're gonna put a pic into the little
yellow book today yes we are coming from
chicago it's the perfect fall treat
we're in that mode straight from the
windy city so this is pumpkin spice
coffee from chicago french press what i
love about this is that it's female
owned it's black owned they make this in
small batches it's with medium roast
coffee beans from el salvador the
pumpkin spice that you're gonna taste is
made in-house and the coffee has notes
of nutmeg and cloves all those things
that make us feel so good inside and i
wanted to taste it together all right
ready one two three here we go don't
burn your mouth i know i hope i don't
do
it
let me tell you something
you know what i love about this it's not
too pumpkiny no right it doesn't go in
your face it's not a word but you
understand what i'm saying right you
know what i like is that often so i'm
new to coffee and i really like creamer
with coffee in it basically i just want
the sugar right so this you get that
pumpkin nice flavor so you don't have to
just douse it with sugar and cream and
all of that it's very
that's what i'm having a hard time
describing but i really like it and it's
very very very delicious so what's cool
about this is that they have a give back
component grinding with the cause so
five percent of proceeds go back to a
501c3 they go back to nonprofits in
chicago and around the country and i
just love that so many chicago
businesses are showing love back to our
community
[Applause]
i love it that's so cool i just love
organizations and businesses that go
back to supporting that to giving back
audrina biges
you are just the best this is the
beginning of a beautiful friendship yes
i love it
i mean seriously
thank you so much for having me on so
great thanks for tasting all the goods
with me from chicago
no problem
okay so thank you so much for choosing
to spend your time with us today we make
this show for you so take this good
energy with you and we hope to see you
again tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]